it was a summit of strong language amid
scenic views leaders of the seven
highest income countries stressed how
united they are in the condemnation of
russia's war in ukraine missile attacks
on kiev and a crowded supermarket in
kramenchuk taking place during the
summit only increased their anger we've
added vita we will continue to hold up
and drive up the economy and political
costs of this war for president putin
and his regime
to that end it's important to stand
together also during the long haul that
will surely be at stake here
and we will also resolutely counter the
russian narrative that this is actually
a conflict where only the west the
so-called global west is condemning this
attack and otherwise the world is
watching what russia is actually doing
that is not the case
leaders acknowledge the fallout of the
war is increasingly being felt around
the world and needs urgent action
but they said little about a possible
solution to a russian blockade of
ukrainian grain
an additional 4.5 billion dollars
package to protect people around the
world against hunger is seen by aid
organizations as disappointing
the focus is on the war in the ukraine
and they found billions and billions of
dollars for that and uh they haven't
found the money uh that we need to fight
hunger for their their own communique
says that over 323 million people
worldwide a new record could face
starvation in the next few months
four and a half billion dollars is a
drop in the ocean for that so it's a
real failure by the g7
with the war in ukraine and the energy
crisis taking nearly all their attention
the main loser here seems to be the
climate a german-led reversal on a ban
for public funding on fossil fuels is
seen by environmental groups as a real
setback
while still depending on russian fossil
fuels for their energy supply g7 leaders
appeared more concerned with lowering
energy prices and trying to reduce
russia's large profits on oil and gas
they agreed to investigate whether to
impose a controversial price cap on
russian oil
the situation is absurd the rise in
global energy prices helps to fund the
war in russia that's the reality so the
idea to cap prices is a very good one
the difficulty is a technical one
russian oil doesn't flow only through
one pipe it's sold in several countries
with many crises unresolved the leaders
are traveling to madrid to join other
nato partners at a summit which will
determine the future of the alliance
al jazeera and garmisch-partenkirchen